our goal is to define a series of
instructions which can prove whether
some input integer is composite or else
identify it as prime with some very high
degree of accuracy which we can define
and it must be efficient to do so
meaning it should be fast to calculate
on any machine and even if the input
size grows which is our input integer n
it should still be fast and so far we've
learned that at the lowest level this
requires some known pattern that all
Prime's follow and very few composites
follow however in the previous video we
did a visual demonstration of fir maas
little theorem and it provides us with a
very interesting rule given some prime
number P and some other integer a which
is just less than P we know now that P
divides a to the power of P minus a we
write this as 8 to the power of P equals
a mod P and that's the way you'll
normally see it
now because a and P share no common
factors since P is a prime we can use
the cancellation law and you'll
sometimes see this written as a to the
power of P minus 1 is 1 mod p and
remember we can only do this because the
greatest common divisor of a and P
equals 1 and here I've just set up a
demo so we can at first just see this
equation in action and get comfortable
with it notice now if I input a prime
for P the output is always 1 no matter
what a I choose if we input a composite
number for P we see that it usually
isn't 1 and any time this equation
outputs something that isn't 1 we have a
composite witness this is now proof that
the P we chose cannot be Prime and
that's the essence of this test and
before going any deeper let's just step
back and and construct the framework for
this test using this pattern I just
showed you so our test starts we are
provided with some integer let's call it
P as input next we generate a random
integer a which is less than P and now
we can ask is the greatest common
divisor of a and P one if not if the
greatest common divisor of an P is
greater than one then they share a
common factor and we've proven that P is
composite because a factor exists and we
can halt and exit and our algorithm will
output composite however if yes and we
can ask the key question does a to the
power of P minus 1 mod p equal 1 if not
we have a witness that P is composite we
can halt and say that we're done P is
composite otherwise if yes if our
equation outputs 1 then it should be
prime right I coded up this series of
instructions and on the left hand side
we have firm AHS tab
on the right I just have an existing
trial division test and that's there
because we know that test is always
corrected and just at first glance it
seems like it's working however I found
a problem I hit the number 511 and now
the firm AHS test is saying its prime
and the trial division test is telling
me that its composite 511 seems prime
from the tests perspective but it's not
now let's just return back to our
equation and see what happened
well this is an example of what we call
a pseudo prime it's a composite number
but there are certain days we can choose
that will output a 1 so it's incorrect
again so these days which result in a
composite number outputting a 1 we can
call fools because they're fooling us
into thinking the number is prime but
notice that if we choose different A's
we seem to find many composite witnesses
instead of fools so we could maybe just
step back and let's apply the same logic
we used in the divisibility test where
we simply repeat the experiment a few
times and generate a new random a each
time and hopefully we won't pick a fool
each time now it's been proven that the
number of fools must divide the total
size of the group we select from which
means at most half of the choices are
half of the elements in this pool could
be fools so since a is chosen randomly
the chance of finding a composite
witness which is what we want is at
least 1/2
after T iterations the probability that
no witness will be found with a
composite number is at most 1/2 to the
power of T so after 20 trials the
probability of mistakenly outputting a
prime is just over one in a million so
that's the case where we just keep
getting really unlucky and generating
random a's and every time we choose a
fool if you can let that sink in that's
really powerful to understand and here
now we can see our test in action
with with the increased number of trials
it seems to be working perfectly
and notice that in the worst case which
we know is when we provide our algorithm
with a prime it's going to do the
maximum amount of work the firm on test
is much more efficient than trial
division especially because the number
of steps doesn't scale with the input
and that's a key distinction we set the
number of trials and that's it we never
have to worry about our algorithm
running millions and millions of
iterations as we did before so I mean
this is quintessentially applied math we
are taking a pattern someone discovered
and we're saving an immense amount of
computational cycles however there is
one tiny flaw or err in this system can
you find it